you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is a game
from the 1961 super tournament between
Bobby Fischer was playing the white side
versus mikhail tall how Fischer opening
with E for tall replying with the
Sicilian defense the game enters an open
system with d4 and to be more exact
after Queen to c7 we have the tamanna'
variation from here g3 prepares to think
head of the bishop also supports the
Queen bishops development and now Knight
to f6 this is already an important point
in the game and I bring this up because
this natural-looking developing move
Knight f6 very common move to be Singh
is one that well if you're playing that
as black you need to be prepared to now
enter a different type of a pawn
structure what am I talking about
exactly well I'm talking about this vet
akov type of pawn structure where if
white makes a couple of moves black will
be forced to move the e6 pawn to e5 and
what do we have we have as veteran ACOG
type of pawn structure normally that
pawn would play up to that a 5 square in
one move but nevertheless even if it
takes 2 steps
same story same type of a pawn structure
and that can be imposed on black and we
see that take shape right away the white
knight makes use of b5 now one thing to
point out is that if you don't want to
eventually be forced into as a veteran
akov type of a structure if you don't
want to as black be forced to play this
'if I've move you had best not develop
your knight right away to f6 but rather
play this a six move keeping the knight
out of b5 but since this square is
available Fischer makes use of it it's
very direct play the Queen is hit she
drops back to b8 the Queen is hit again
and this is the point where now this e
five move is objectively best and it's
not the move which is played again if
this move is played we have as much in
common structure d5 is weakened y can be
replying with Bishop g5 looking to not
only remove the number one defender of
d5 but also smash open the black ink
side structure we don't have that Tolley
likes to keep
structure as is and works the night into
a pin Knight to e5
this last move move eight is the one
which practically loses the game it's a
big big decision at this point and I
believe even further back that moves six
because if you're not again wanting to
play this e5 movie it really shouldn't
be playing the knight f6 move at this
point it's big trouble for black and
white will be decide who is throwing all
the punches and black is on their heels
so let's see exactly what takes place
the Queen would love to play to d4 at
this point adding more fuel to that
pinned piece but not so fast there would
be Knight f3
so let's first watch over that f3
squared Bishop e2 does just that
and this is a curious move in itself
because it's a typical what's more
typical is to play to g2 you've played
to g3 you've played your pawn up to g3
normally you're going to Fink cut of the
bishop and from g2 we'll be watching
over f3 so why isn't that move played
and these are questions you could be
asking of yourself if you're seeing your
opponent make these type of a move these
type of moves where you see in a typical
move namely Bishop e2 you should now
question what are the differences
between the atypical Bishop e2 and the
typical Bishop g2 well here's one of the
differences from e2 it watches over the
c-4 square which is regarded on the
white side as being one of the softest
squares when you're playing against an
open Sicilian it keeps this Knight out
of that c4 point a knight from that
square can be quite annoying and it also
of course addresses this f3 square so it
watches about c4 and f3 whereas if it
was on g2 it's specifically just an f3
coverage
so from here Bishop c5 keeps the Queen
out of d4 and attempts at trying to shoo
this night away with a6 can actually be
ignored white could still play up to d4
piling up on the pinned piece if the
knight is defended white can yet again
ignore the threat on the night and just
castle if the knight is taken you grab
the knight if there is a
caPSURE black is dead so we're not
having that instead it's just Bishop c5
Bishop takes Knight very direct play the
queen is recapturing of course f4 there
is only one reply the queen drops back
to being 'if I've very limited replies
very direct play the night where does he
do does he go home if he goes home
Knight e4 this bishops hit a night on
that d5 square I was talking in his
veteran college structure a knight on d5
again with this black pawn if it's on e5
a knight on d5 would be wonderful
shifted up one rank if there's a knight
getting to d6 he's priceless absolutely
priceless all the more valuable so that
cannot be allowed for sure instead what
we have is the counter attacking attempt
with a six now what is it that allows
white to go in for this this idea of
grabbing the knight and then following
up with that for a 5 well what's exactly
going on
you give up your Bishop pair that's one
thing so you better have something to
show for it
so what is shown for it well White's
grabbing space and doing so with gain of
time cleanness it more space is being
gained and now there's a support point
on the weakest point in the black
position d6
with tempo hitting the knight yet again
and well even though white doesn't have
that dark square bishop his friends are
around the pawns on dark squares in
particular to watch over those squares
and keep in mind this Bishop not doing a
lot in this position is he so white also
has still a lead in development so these
are some factors that you can be looking
into you usually have to show something
for giving up the bishop pair white has
enough to show for it
so a6 from here pawn takes Knight pawn
takes Knight pawn takes pawn rook g8 94
the bishop is hit these are all
reactionary moves by black we've been
seeing a lot of this has to cover f6
otherwise there would be a fork Queen d4
looking to jump into that f6 square and
now rook to a rook to a 4-1 other try
that
black maybe be going with is to try and
get the Queens off the board certainly
when you do a king comparison the black
king is the more vulnerable so maybe
something along the lines of Queen a4
and maybe trying to let's say okay first
give a check and then come back here I'm
not sure the exact moves with the idea
the main idea that I want to bring your
attention to is trying to get these
Queens off the board it's not something
that tall goes forward with instead it
is rook to a four and now still comes
Knight to f6 and he has to be captured
playing the King to d8 allows Queen b6
in the rook will be captured in short
order so Bishop takes Knight Queen
recaptures Queen c7 hits C - its
defended and this pawn is allowed to be
captured and keep in mind with that last
move by white fully developed and this
Bishop remains on its home square and
it's still - moves off from even moving
it's kind of odd to see both b7 and d7
well the B and D pawns still in their
home squares so black grabs that a -
pawn king b1 defends stops the rook from
coming to a1 and other rook drops back
it might be a bit tempting to play the
move Queen to a5 because it threatens me
and one but there's a good reason to not
make a move such as that what's the
reason well after something is
convenient as b3 what do you do now is
black I use the word convenient by the
way because the Queen is a good
defensive piece and she is still
functioning in an aggressive way she's
on this f6 outpost and she can't be
dislodged she's watching over this pond
who's just a single step away from
queening and unless there's an
additional ingredient that black could
throw into the mix unless there's an
additional attacker that black can throw
in to try and get at that white the
white king this Queen is essentially
just tied down to the to the defense of
the rook not a situation you really want
to be in
so instead after King b1 the rook comes
back Bishop takes pawn
rook b6 Bishop d3 white looks to grab on
h7 and then the rook yeah and so as a
reply we have E 5 now this is the point
in the game where if you'd like to pause
the video see if you can find the move
that Fischer played at this point move
number 23 okay
the move that Fischer played at this
point was F takes e allowing the Queen
to be captured and it is rook takes
Queen pawn takes rook and there's
nothing that could be done about this
pawn being taken and also the rook being
taken Queen c5 Bishop takes Queen g5
Bishop takes rook this is all pretty
much forced and after the smoke clears
what we end up having is a very unwell
it's unbalanced position and it's
stripped down to what exactly two rooks
versus the Queen and the only thing that
White is needing to watch out for is the
potential for a perpetual check so white
does well to try and stay coordinated
first we have a couple checks being
thrown in and eventually a white rook
drops back to the first rank making sure
that the queen is not going to be giving
perpetual in any way pumps up the route
gets right behind it G for the pawn
isn't taken at this point okay we had
Queen h3 the pond isn't taken because
rook h1 and no matter what black does
next rook to h8 or in other words if the
Queen tries to still defend this square
you still play to h8 and then eventually
you get the Queen so that's why we're
not having this Queen grab on g4 instead
Queen h3 the pawn marches on the rook
gives a check getting out of the way of
the Queen finally that pawn is taken the
King tries to get off of that back rank
but white says go no further
sixth rank is now under control and soon
the game plan for here for white will be
to control the seventh rank once the
seventh rank is under
control to then get on that
eighth-ranked let's see how that takes
shape d1 eventually both rooks around
the 6th rank b3 an additional flight
square for the king b2 and a 2 now
available King just shuffling on h7 and
after rook to a6 tal ends up resigning
and there's nothing that could be done
the threat here is again to get either
one of these rooks to the seventh rank
and then eventually control the eighth
rank if both of these rook moves are
prevented the Queen would be having to
play to either b7 or c7 if she plays to
either one of these this is what can
follow a bunch of checks and eventually
the queen is lost by force and similarly
if we have let's say the Queen not
playing to either one of these squares
and instead just sticks around on this
eighth rank we could have check on the
seventh both rooks are now on the
seventh and a similar story again if the
Queen hangs around on now b8 or c8 we
have these checks thrown in and once
again the Queen will be lost so as it
stands in this game after this 47th move
rook to a six black ends up resigning so
pretty impressive game interesting to
see how important it could be at that
very early stage move six to have that
Knight f6 move if you don't want to
obtain that for you don't if you don't
want to go into that suggestion there's
a fashion kind of structure then you
should be playing that a6 move on move
six but as it went in that game move
eight Knight to e5 it was already at
that point black being on their heels
and they had a tough road ahead weren't
able to recover so that's all for this
video as always I hope you got something
out of it take care bye
you